if you haven't got anything to hide you
don't have anything to fear that's what
a lot of people will argue but what if
your data gets misused say you've got on
holidays to the middle east for a
language course and you write to a
friend but omit the fact that it was to
learn Arabic because your friend already
knows this and suddenly you've got a
message that reads just returned from
training in Yemen how would that sound
to the authorities that's a question for
you are in bula from the association bit
calm is it that simple can you get
yourself into so much trouble so quickly
well to be honest I don't know because
nobody knows actually now what the
secret services worldwide do what they
are doing and what what they can do when
they read such an email and this is one
of the biggest problems we don't know
what they do and on which loss they do
it but we know that they are looking or
do have the capabilities of looking at
our data and our information yes that
that's true they have the capability but
we don't know how to get how they get
the datas whether they get it via the
cable or do they are they using
technologies for hacking or stuff like
that that's not clear at the moment and
we we are still waiting for answers from
from the government in the US or in the
UK as well as from the German government
are the answers were ever going to get
well how to say we hope so where we
actually need it because we what what we
what we see now is that we are losing
trust in our technologies and that's a
very big problem not only for for
holidays in the Middle East but for the
economy is a very big problem our
economy is based on data as the data is
very important for our economy and and
if we if you lose trust in these
technologies then we will lose economy
welfare I mean this is something that it
sounds like you're trying to say we
should be outraged about we should be
doing something about this yes well we
definitely do we have to do we need
agreements no spy agreements we need a
loss what the secret services should do
what they are not allowed to do and to
get more trust in our technologies again
and this is this is a
this is homework to do for politics what
a company is doing because company
companies were involved they with a
middleman so to speak for some
government well first of all the
companies want to say what they are
doing with the government and what they
are not at the moment they are not
allowed to talk about it and this is the
first problem we need transparency but
very big issue for them and the second
thing is that we we have to in spirit II
as well for our data security what our
company is doing for to secure the datas
what are they doing and technologies and
what are they doing with lures and what
what oh yeah well what's the company
dealing with their data what about
German companies well the German company
is there there is no difference between
German companies or other companies data
protection is a very big issues for both
of them and yes and this is the this is
a point that they have to do it and what
about government Edward Snowden has said
a mission accomplished now we have to
urge governments to end the mass data
sifting that they've been doing I mean
is that pie in the sky well I think so I
mean it's a little bit naive to think
that the government will stop the secret
service activities but what we can do is
to agree what they allow to do and what
not and what they allowed to do with
different states and what are they
allowed for domestic people and foreign
people and I think we have to talk about
it and we need laws and we need
transparency for for other secret
services yes mr. Gowda thank you very
much for the analysis you're welcome